ils ont eu une mention au brevet ou au
bac sont devenus infirmiers se sont
illustrés comme sportif où se sont
engagé dans l'humanitaire
vendredi soir c'est trappistes ont été
récompensés par la ville lors de la
soirée des réussites se contente d'être
ici et savoir que tout le travail que
j'ai fait bah au moins ils devraient
compenser je n'ai pas fait ça que c'est
pas fait ça en revanche c'est quand même
valorisant de beau de pouvoir déjà
partager sa réussite avec les autres et
de voir que battre ap
il ya beaucoup de jeunes comme ça et ils
réussissent on a commencé la première
soirée des réussites avec une
quarantaine de jeunes nous en sommes là
à 150 sans avoir changé les niveaux et
les critères qui font qu'on a une
récompense en mon sens noble du terme à
cette soirée de la réussite cette année
la soirée était parrainée par ahmed agne
fondateur et directeur éditorial de
couilles une maison d'édition de manga
aujourd'hui moi je leur parlais un petit
peu de mon parcours de ce que je fais
sans m'ériger en modèle pour pour autant
parce que je pense qu'il ya pas un
modèle de réussite il ya plein de
manières d'envisager son avenir
personnel et professionnel et voilà le
mien c'en est un parmi d'autres et
j'espère que certains d'entre eux
peut-être prouvons quelconque
inspiration on va dire qu elle les
lauréats se sont vu remettre ce soir là
un ordinateur portable encore des bons
d'achat depuis sa création en 2004 plus
de 2000 jeunes ont été récompensés
[Applaudissements]